2.8 trillion parameters, open weights,
sitting on a public download page right
now for free. That is the largest open
weight model anyone has ever shipped,
and it landed 3 days ago. 48 hours
later, somebody had it writing tokens on
a laptop. A 2021 M1 Max, 64 gigs of RAM.
The measured speed was 14.6 seconds per
token, not tokens per second, seconds
per token. One word is roughly a minute
of waiting. A short paragraph is most of
an afternoon, and the hacker news thread
went straight to war over whether that
is impressive or completely pointless.
Here is why the speed is what it is.
Kimiko 3 is a mixture of experts model.
It only touches a sliver of itself per
token. Kimiko carries 896 experts per
layer, 16 fire on any given pass. But 16
experts across 92 layers still means
25.8 GB of RAMs per token. So, three
things to settle: what actually shipped,
what it cost to hold it, and whether any
of it is useful. Start with the file,
because the file is the story. 1.56
terabytes of weights publicly
downloadable. Kimiko 3 is from Moonshot
AI in Beijing. 2.8 trillion parameters
total. 104 billion active on any given
token. 93 layers. A vision encoder on
the front and a context window of 1
million tokens. 69 of those 93 layers
run something called Kimiko Delta
attention. Instead of a key-value cache
that grows with every token you feed it,
it holds a fixed size recurrent state
with per channel forget gates. The other
24 layers are gated latent attention.
That mix is why a million token window
is even on the table at this size. Three
out of every four attention layers stop
the cache from exploding. So, the memory
wall moves off the cache and onto the
weights themselves. Hold onto that. It
decides everything later. On the front
end code arena, real people voting on
which model built the better interface,
K3 sits at the top. LO of 1,679.
Claude Sonnet 5 is second at 1,631.
GPT-4.5 is third at 1,618.
It took first place in six of the seven
categories they score. Brand work,
reference based design, data and
analytics, consumer product simulations,
and content tools. The one it lost was
gaming, where Sonnet 5 still holds the
edge. On the harder benchmarks, it is
closer to a coin flip. GPQA Diamond, the
graduate level science set, 93.5 for K3,
94.1 for GPT-4.5.
Terminal Bench 2.1, agents doing real
shell work, 88.3 against 88.8. But on
BrowseComp, where the model has to find
things on the live web, K3 takes it
outright. 91.2
to 90.4. The license is not MIT, and
that is worth reading before you build a
company on it. Moonshot wrote their own
document. You can download it, run it,
fine-tune it. But commercial inference
above 20 million dollars annual revenue
triggers a separate arrangement with
them. 99,000
downloads in a month. 8,000 likes on the
model page for a file the overwhelming
majority of those people cannot
physically store. And for scale, the
previous Kimi was around a trillion
parameters. This is the steepest single
generation jump the open weight chart
has seen. So why is a 2.8 trillion
parameter model only 1.56 terabytes on
disk? In BF16, 2 bytes a parameter, it
would be around 5.6 terabytes. The
format is MXFP4. Four-bit block floating
point, where a group of weights shares
one scale factor, and each weight keeps
four bits of its own. Native on
Blackwell and MI355
class silicon, and it is applied
selectively. The expert weights, which
are the bulk of the model, go to four
bits. The routers and attention
projections stay higher, because those
are the parts where a rounding error
turns into a wrong answer instead of a
slightly worse one. Here is the part
that matters most. Moonshot did not
quantize this afterwards. They trained
it that way. Quantization aware training
running through supervised fine-tuning
and reinforcement learning both. So, the
model learned to live at 4-bits rather
than getting squeezed into them at the
end, which means the 4-bit file you
download is the same precision the paid
API serves you. Their co-founders
confirmed exactly that in an AMA the day
the weights went up. Then, Unsloth
shipped a quant ladder on top of it,
which is the thing that turns a data
center artifact into something a very
determined person can attempt at home.
The smallest build is UDiQ1S at 594 GB.
1-bit M is 649.
2-bit XXS is 711.
2-bit XL is 861.
4-bit lands at 1.51 TB and 8-bit at
1.56, same size as the original. And you
pay for every step down that ladder. The
1-bit S build agrees with the full model
on 78.9%
of next token picks. 2-bit XL gets that
to 90.4. 4-bit is effectively the
original. One correction while we are
here. You will see 555 GB quoted for the
1-bit build in a few places. I went
looking and could not find it on the
published table. The number today is
594.
Boring beats wrong, which brings us back
to the laptop. The project is called
Deltafin. It went up 2 days ago from a
developer publishing as GAA media, MIT
licensed. Sitting at 274 stars as I
record this. It splits the model in half
conceptually. There is a resident spine,
the attention layers, the shared
experts, the latent projections, the
embeddings. About 114 GB quantized down
to 60 in INT8, read layer by layer off
local storage for every token. And then
there is everything else. 80 2,432
routed experts, roughly 1.45 TB of them.
So, Deltafin does not load them. For
each token, the router names 16 experts
per layer. It reads exactly those, one
HTTP range request per expert, 17
megabytes at a time, into a disk cache
that grows as you use it. Do that
arithmetic and you get the number this
whole project lives or dies on. 16
experts, 92 layers, 25.8 GB of reading
for one token. Off a local SSD that is
about 4 seconds. Streamed over a
network, it is 3 minutes. Now the part
that made me stop scrolling. The first
working version took 24,429
seconds to produce a first token, 40
minutes for one token. The current
benchmark on the same machine is 28
seconds. Steady decode went the same
way. Roughly 20 minutes a token down to
14.6 seconds. That is about 82 times
faster. And this is version one of a
project that is two days old. The
speedups are unglamorous and specific,
which is exactly how you know they are
real. A fused kernel that dequantizes
MXFP4 and runs the matrix vector
multiply in one pass. Neon on Apple
Silicon, AVX2 on X86, and int8 spine
that halves per token IO. A packed
output head worth 17% on its own. And it
stays exact. Greedy decoding, lossless
n-gram speculation. Same prompt produces
the same tokens, run after run. The
limitations are stated plainly in the
readme, which I appreciate. Greedy only.
Temperature and top P are ignored
entirely. One request at a time. A
second concurrent request gets a 429.
And long prompts are expensive because
prefill has to touch far more experts
than decode does. You also need the
disk. 1.7 terabytes for a full local
install, 5 to 10 hours to pull it down,
or 215 GB if you keep the cache small
and stream the rest on demand at 3
minutes a token. Somebody in the
community ran the same code on an Nvidia
DGX Spark instead. BF16 on CPU took 865
seconds. And eight on CUDA took 221.
So, back to that thread, 136 points, 90
comments. Almost all of it is one
argument having itself over and over. A
commenter called Secrelist put the case
against it as bluntly as it can be put.
No one will ever drive any utility from
running models at this speed. Give me
the use case. Give me the token counts.
And the arithmetic is on his side. 1,000
output tokens at 14.6 seconds each is 4
hours of your machine doing nothing
else. The same thousand tokens through
Moonshot's API cost about 1.5 cents and
arrive before you finish reading this
sentence. The author's answer is the
line I keep turning over. He said the
interface matters more than the raw
rate, and then added that he can
probably only write about a thousand
good tokens in a day himself, which is
either a dodge or the most useful
sentence in the thread. A third
commenter re- framed it completely. It's
fun. And it answers the question of what
happens if you wake up tomorrow and the
data centers are gone. Weights on your
own desk are the one version of a model
that cannot be switched off from
somewhere else. The maintainer refuses
to oversell it. The readme says in plain
words that this is a research artifact
and not a practical chat setup. He calls
it an existence proof and a test bed for
streaming inference. That is the correct
claim to make. Meanwhile, on the model
page, somebody asked the obvious
question. Can I run this on my MacBook?
The first replies were a stack of maybe
eight H200, then 12 H200 or nine B200.
The third reply pointed straight at
Deltafin and noted the author had made a
lot of progress in about 12 hours. If
you want to serve it properly, one
eight-way B300 node gives you around 2.3
terabytes of memory, which fits the
weights plus the KV cache at a million
tokens of context on a single machine.
Even the smallest one-bit quant asks for
610 GB of RAM and VRAM combined before
it will load. Two-bit XL wants 880. And
here's the awkward bit of timing. Back
in March, Apple pulled the 512 GB option
off the Mac Studio configurator entirely
and raised the price of the 256 upgrade
by $400. Memory shortage. The consumer
ceiling is 256 now. So, the one machine
a person could reasonably own that
almost held this model stopped being
affordable in the same year the model
shipped. The frontier became
downloadable and the hardware to run it
got harder to buy. Both of those are
true at the same time. K3 was not the
only drop this week. SK Telecom put AXK2
on Hugging Face. 688 billion parameters,
open weights, built in Korea, aimed
squarely at manufacturing, defense, and
biotech. Across 14 benchmarks, it
averages 32 points above the model it
replaces. Long context and agent scores
moved by roughly 84. They have said the
next one is aiming at the trillion mark.
Line the shelf up and it looks nothing
like it did in spring. Kim K3 at 2.8
trillion, Deep Seek V4 Pro at 1.6
trillion, GLM 5.2 at 744 billion with 40
billion active, smaller than K3 and
still scoring above it on the aggregate
intelligence index. Parameter count
stopped being the score a while ago, but
the bottleneck did move. Getting hold of
frontier weights used to be the hard
part. Now, it is a download link. The
hard part is having somewhere to put 1.5
terabytes and enough read bandwidth to
pull 26 GB per token. 14.6 seconds a
token is not a product. It is a receipt.
It says the model is a file, the file is
on your disk, and everything between
that and a usable assistant is
engineering rather than permission. And
engineering is the thing that went 82
times faster in a fortnight. Deltafin,
the unsought quants, and the model card
are all linked below. If you have got
the disk, the readme is a good hour.
Thanks for watching.